citizens of the reject Nation Greg here
today three things I gotta update you on
one first update apologies for being
late to why I'm late is because uh we
are currently trying to prep uh videos
to go up for the whole weekend because
we are going to be having our Comic-Con
panel this coming Saturday one o'clock
P.M if you're at Comic-Con please come
by say hi would love to have you in
attendance McCoy is actually hosting a
haulage panel right now as we speak
thris you guys might know that we've
been partnered with shopzeroedition.com
but we no longer will be partnering with
them starting at the end of July and
originally this shirt right here a soda
was supposed to drop in August but right
now they're letting us drop it for the
next 10 days after July 31st it will no
longer be available so right now is the
one and only opportunity to grab
yourself in a soda shirt I got one
coming in the mail right now anywho we
got ourselves a Spider-Man 2 story
trailer thank you guys so much for being
here I am excited to check this out
let's do it
Lots happened in the last 10 years
it's a miracle I'm even sitting here now
I got a second chance
I'm gonna take advantage of that
but I need you with me Pete
you're gonna Heal the World
Amazing Spider-Man 2 Vibes here
guys this is my best friend Harry hi
Harry good to meet you good job huh
still gonna have time for tutoring
figure it out
I didn't know there were bears in these
Woods
MJ
I have another name for you Craven oh
bad he's here on some kind of hunt
I'm just a call away
what you took for me
well miles talks about is how to be a
better Spider-Man
how to help you the hell is going on
with me he's not himself go help him
oh wow this was our dreams
we're going to heal the world
chills oh look how I think it looks yes
oh my goodness
that looks awesome man
I am so thrilled I'm thrilled
look I gotta keep it relatively quick
because I still got a little bit more to
work on before we head out however man I
mean I really love the first game and
this game seems to just be a solid
continuation of it some of the mood or
themes or some of the commentary that I
feel like that this story might
ultimately be exploring it kind of seems
like it's doing a combination of
story elements we saw an Amazing
Spider-Man 2 and Spider-Man 3 the Toby
Maguire one which is funny to me because
both of those movies are are not well
received obviously I actually really
like Amazing Spider-Man too believe it
or not with the story points that you
have of like Harry and Peter and what
Harry is dealing with you know probably
not just you know physically but also
emotionally and then of course you're
having Venom here but before Venom shows
up you're going to be having Peter
dealing with having the you know the
symbiote suit on him and of course
probably dealing with Craven the hunter
while he's symbiosis imbued I like
seeing both of those qualities put
together and I imagine it's going to be
better than both of those movies
combined because we know how great
Insomniac is with the storytelling and
with Spider-Man so much of the theme
seem to be dealing with what depths of
darkness my one descend to In The Name
of Love It seems like a lot of this at
the end of the day is rooted in you know
like Peter wanted to be a better
protector miles wanted to be a better
protector but even miles you see here is
faced with the choice of Vengeance as
well he's squaring off with Lee who's
confirmed to be returning now and you
know we have Lee there and then you
already have all these other villains
but miles I don't imagine is going to
ever have a simile suit in this story
however
he's having a choice right now where he
is confronted with Lee and he looks like
he wants to take action against him and
then you have Norman Osborne as well
who's already in his own dark path
already because he's Norman Osborne but
what he's doing you know with Harry
which obviously is not going to be good
for Harry he's doing in the Name of Love
ultimately I kind of think that's like a
neat through line where we're going to
be watching our characters who you know
are supposed to be this representation
of heroism and hope ultimately having to
face the darkness within and the base
best way to do the darkness within when
you're doing a story of like literally
competing with physical darkness is
watch how our character's Darkness
ultimately manifest and how they have to
overcome that showing the Divide between
villain and anti-hero versus hero I
think it's really solid stuff it's the
trailer seems to confirm right that
based off of the beginning parts of it
the the ending of Spider-Man one and the
fact that the two lines mirror each
other and then you have the Venom
dialogue
hovering over Harry at the very end it
would seem to confirm that Harry Osborne
is indeed the one to become venom and I
am wondering you know what moral
consequences or self-blame because it's
Peter of what he might take on with this
I do think that makes for a more
personal story obviously you know
traditionally speaking Venom would kick
off with Eddie Brock but if the story is
starting off with Peter Parker as a
symbiote and then he manages to uh
alleviate himself of that and then It
ultimately transfers to Harry where the
bond is even stronger and instead of
being able to get rid of the evil he has
now given this you know rebirth to Harry
I can imagine that that amount of guilt
would weigh heavily on Peter so what I'm
bringing all this up for is that while
there's a lot of really cool visuals
here whether a lot of really cool action
at the end of the day this is a story
trailer and to me it would appear that
as a story trailer they have a really
solid story on their hands they have
obviously great visuals great action
scenes and whatnot and the things that
you'd want to show up for as a gamer for
this beloved game but in terms of a
story it's more than just plot it looks
like it's going to be able to keep it
character driven while you're going
through this plotter you know if you're
going to go darker odds are it's going
to make it more personal and it does
seem like that it'll have a lot of these
really strong personal entanglements
amongst friends and who we Define as
family even if they're not blood but
then also it will deal with the
consequences that we put upon the ones
that we love who are our blood you know
because we didn't even really hone in
that much on on craving the hunter that
might be one of my little concerns it's
not a major concern because video games
are obviously way longer than movies
because you know I'm going to the fact
in my mind of how whatever a Spider-Man
movie usually tends to jam-pack their
films I'm not not always but when they
Jam back their films with a bunch of
villains or what have you it it can feel
like not enough got enough service time
on screen or enough exploration not
enough time to really hang out with all
these characters but it's a video game
so they're gonna be around for an
obnoxiously a long time and it's way
longer than a movie so I feel like the
craving the hunter story will be better
served for you know Peter when he's in
the symbiote suit assuming assuming and
by the way I still feel like I pronounce
it symbiote right am I pronouncing it
right I feel like I'm pronouncing it
right I feel like that story will go to
serve Peter really well because he's
going to be dealing with a character
who's challenging him to his deepest
darkest depths and he's gonna have to
not resort to like killing this guy who
would instantly murder him and was
probably putting other civilians at risk
uh just to get to Spider-Man himself
they got a lot of great set up here uh
about you know revenge and they're
probably going to have the conversation
about killing and what is a when is it
okay to kill
is Peter making really a difference did
the Spider-Man really make a difference
if these villains just keep coming back
I think there's a lot of strong
potential here to do something that is
actually more impactful than the first
game and you know what yeah venom does
look awesome Venom looks incredible I
love that you know that what is that
that Spike punch moment it all shoots
out at one point in the game it was
awesome I thought this was an incredible
trailer and my one little concern is
maybe Craven doesn't get as fleshed out
or as serviceable as a story as we're
hoping for but that is such a minor like
it's not real if anything I'm just
looking for a concern I really feel like
it saw me ultimately won't deliver on
that uh I mean they will deliberately I
feel like they won't fail to deliver
guys what did you think about the
trailer please leave your thoughts down
below those are uh my thoughts on it and
yeah this might this might be the first
game I'm gonna try to set it up this
might be the first game where we we
stream it here uh to you know because I
really do love it and uh yeah but guys
check us out Comic Con if you're gonna
be attending a soda shirt that's
available right now on shopzero
edition.com thank you guys so much for
being here I'll talk with you all soon
rejack Nation
thank you